one of the main obstacles that's
standing between bitcoin reaching global
adoption is the u.s tax code right now
if you spend bitcoin any amount you get
hit with capital gains tax think about
if you go to dinner and you buy it with
us dollars you simply buy the meal you
pay your sales tax and you tip the
waiter you walk out of the restaurant
and all is good in the world but if you
were to buy that same exact meal in
bitcoin you still would pay for the meal
the sales tax and tip the waiter but
then you'd get hit with capital gains
tax that doesn't make it very attractive
for people to use bitcoin as a medium of
exchange to buy goods and services in
their everyday life but now there's
politicians on both sides of the aisle
that are coming together and they're
trying to address this problem we have a
brand new bipartisan bill that's been
put forward that would exempt small 50
bitcoin and cryptocurrency transactions
from capital gains taxes according to
coin center they said that this could
pave the way for bitcoin to be used for
retail payments subscription services
and micro transactions now that sounds
really promising but there's more
details to it here's a cnbc reporter
explaining exactly what people are
proposing with this brand new piece of
legislation new this morning a
bipartisan pair of senators floating an
idea that could make paying with
cryptocurrency much more of an everyday
thing elon moyer joins us with the
latest on that good morning well good
morning andrew that bill is being
introduced today and it would allow
consumers to buy things with bitcoin
without having to worry about paying a
capital gains tax now this proposal
comes from republican senator pat toomey
and democrat kirsten cinema the goal is
to encourage public adoption of
cryptocurrency by making it easier to
conduct everyday purchases right now if
you buy something with bitcoin even just
a cup of coffee you could technically
owe the irs capital gains tax on the
crypto that you used the virtual
currency tax fairness act would exempt
transactions of less than 50 dollars
from that requirement in a statement
senator toomey said quote while digital
currencies have the potential to become
an ordinary part of americans everyday
lives our current tax code stands in the
way now congress has been discussing a
slew of crypto legislation over the past
few months amid all this market
volatility but so far none of them have
gone very far a bill to regulate stable
coins that the house had hoped to
formally debate this week has been
punted until after summer recess so
we'll see how much momentum this new
crypto tax bill picks up but guys it's
clear that congress is watching the
industry closely most of you who hear
this they're gonna say wow that sounds
awesome 50 or less and i don't have to
pay capital gains tax but i'm not so
enthusiastic about this and the reason
is it doesn't pass the dinner test
what's the dinner test if you have to go
to dinner and buy it with bitcoin it's
usually more than 50 bucks and if dinner
can't be purchased with bitcoin without
paying capital gains tax then what's the
point of having any sort of de minimis
exemption build ultimately a de minimis
exemption is important but 50 is
laughable we need to get it up five
hundred dollars or a thousand dollars
there are so many things in an economy
that cost more than fifty dollars
especially with inflation over nine
percent and so ultimately this is the
right idea but i question the execution
should it not be more than 50
500 or more and then i'll start getting
excited
ultimately the tax code stands in the
way of more global adoption it prevents
people from spending their bitcoin and
if we want bitcoin to transition from
simply a store of value to a medium of
exchange we're gonna have to change that
tax code it's gonna be an important step
kudos to these politicians coming
together across the aisle and trying to
push this forward but i think we gotta
raise that limit in order for it to make
sense